how scum Roseman is here to pack we're
playing octa dad shorts it's a dlc that
just came out for Octodad we play the
first one oh god the music is so
annoying
it's like outta tune who Alex well well
hmm this is a story about dad can I move
oh hello
yeah whoo what shop left no hospital why
no God plane thank you doctor yeah let
me be a doctor please doctor hey babe
wow thanks all right I'm here I think
all right what's up what happens next
and then hi nurse friends who's gonna
nurse today if not my nips need nursing
if you know what I mean look I don't
sorry that's sexual harassment don't sue
me get to the nurse's station
how is this not the nurse station what's
the nurse station are you a nurse
station
okay this I find patient records do you
have nothing better to do than stare at
me all day [ __ ] this one no is she
doing to that poor chair what does she
do what is key who put Kiwis limes huh
okay let's start with 205 205 baby are
you 205 is one guy with a jerk your jerk
oh yeah right well what's that bottom
her so just my bed nurse I can massage
your I can massage your boot if you want
in and then oh he likes it he lucky lots
adjust the bed um I don't think I'm
called a fight for this um how do I
adjust the damn bed um that's my foot
I'm think I'm killing this guy oh god
sorry there's a fork in his ass no
wonder it hurts are there you go this is
the bed okay
there we go okay there you go you want
you want in may again sorry I don't mean
to be sexual but you yes I'd throw my
neck - that's not creepy at all
come on yes here comes the choo-choo
train boom [ __ ] smear it all over eat
it eat oh there you go that's a good boy
you want another slice you want another
slice [ __ ] mmm there you go give me a
book a book all right wants it back I'll
give you a book no problem a signed one
seen a book help I don't know where the
books are maybe there's a book in the
waiting room there we go all right I got
I got the book that is another book what
kind of book is this a red book that
she'll do it yeah yeah don't worry about
it
there you go get that stupid book buddy
patient new IV again what is wrong with
this one I don't understand that we can
complain about the service it's
impeccable good thing I know where they
are at least now hello yes get it get
the IV brush I need you to stop judging
me for not being very good all right
thanks I want some IV can't you see I
got some IV that I paid in okay out put
a banana peel here I'm sick of your ass
ah you want my ass
no [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] go all right
oh I think I stabbed someone I better go
better go okay
fluff patient 101 spill oh I can do that
[ __ ] with my eyes closed hey babe what's
up you're pregnant all right we fluffed
a pillow now let's turn up the TV with
my chair
ah that'll do it she wanted to be
fluffed again how many fluffs is a
pillow need doughnuts yes why would
there not be doughnuts at a hospital
that makes sense okay try and see it
every gal get my mama mone
my mama mone m36 MLG noscope moneygrab
donut which one is a donut one oh god
what I get stupid CDs or some [ __ ] I've
got it now they're stuck all the donut
started to pet him ah there we go
alright alright I got it I got it I got
it I got it whoo my money my money
that's that's the best song I ever wrote
it's called money money money
all right here you go babe I got your
Donuts infinite supply it's very good
she just went into a coma that sugar
rush was too much fill the pressure
meter
what's a pressure meter and why would I
fill it
there you go you're welcome it must be
another patient right
there we go yeah you know I babe let me
just fill the pressure up don't take
this in the wrong way but I'm putting
pressure hey did you know she likes it
look at that Texas this perverted sounds
make it really awkward or is it just me
um okay oh god I'm doing really badly
here
how do I shine in her damn eyes it's
chatting anywhere anywhere but her eyes
look at that why would you want me to
shine them in your eyes at okay enough I
feel like is it I'll give it to miss
trade nurse and get peed somewhere
pretty table come on
watch what is it woman want from me
excuse me lady
well I can see you enjoy em how's the
hospital bed
Oh what happened what the hell
uh okay well I'm I'm glad you enjoy the
whiteboard yes now where the hell is the
whiteboard why is everyone looking at me
god it's not easy being a nurse ah why
is life so hard where this oh there it
is alright alright alright I'll show you
too babe alright red wish it's my
favorite uh so alright so this is you
right
alright and then this is me and then
this is life and this is risk of all but
one column every bit of a my own drugs I
think I'm on drugs
what
now what the actual [ __ ] this happened
oh okay
come on the phone is pointed by Eric's
brother what's up dad it's your
long-lost brother Oh terrible news for
you oh no what patients is going into
cardiac arrest oh no I better go into
surgery why what's wrong with what
happened what happened what how did it
get in that sexy position only I can be
in sexy positions all right get back in
bed [ __ ] there you go
you're fine no no hospital II think they
say on TV we need to raise the flaps
yeah it isn't very much illegal breaking
bad applied it everywhere how do I raise
the flaps goddamn flaps sit the [ __ ]
down and the bet L to sit down [ __ ] all
right well I got your gnomey all right
it's just doing yoga I don't even worry
about it
oh it's beautiful uh how do I adjust
stupid flaps I swear to god the flaps
are like unflappable what happened to my
long oh there we go
all right I did it with sheer manpower
there we go whoo all right we gotta go
gotta go fast sonic mode activate we're
gonna taste a most fearsome challenge
that opening a door with it opening a
door with a chair yeah
ah nailed it nailed it I think my leg is
stuck but I nailed it
yes oh that door was the challenge no ha
ha ok um let me just get right to that
that's right ain't nobody [ __ ] with me
and crowbar
alright what's going on here oh there we
go
ok I don't think I was supposed to okay
well that explains everything in life
yeah whoo stop me and chair are here
gret get him to the prep room who's him
with who the [ __ ] it's gotta go fast
gotta go fast gotta go so face alright
girl up there we go
cut come with me if you want to live Wow
Oh watch out lady
they gotta get this man to a hospital
ASAP wait we are at a hospital ah don't
worry man you're gonna live you're gonna
live and you're gonna be beautiful
yes this is plastic surgery baby wash
your hands come on that's just that's
just an unnecessary precaution ok why do
I wash my hands where do I wash my hands
seriously it must be a sink or something
somewhere uh oh there's a sink alright
alright let's wash his hands wash your
damn hands woman we pulled it off give
him anesthesia all right oh no my
brother my lovin my loving brother you
need to live there you go
all right let's go to the table I'll
save you if the last thing I'll do yeah
ah you're too fat grab him Turner cutter
ba ba ba ba
ah why what do you want from me huh what
do you want from me man hey look guys
he's alive it's fine this is dancing is
Erica nailed it dr. Nigel hey is this a
surgeon simulator reference oh yeah this
is after that all right
h-hey right yeah I know I did the trick
thank God he looks so hot wait for dr.
Nigel all right Alec better look good oh
my god well we knew that x-ray the
patient all right it looks pretty dead
to me but I guess we'll x-ray him anyway
sorry dr. Nigel I'll do my best
senpai senpai Nigel x rays face because
that's not at all toxic Nigel want a
scalpel I want to look at this x-ray
scan we don't even look at the scans
this is like a please x-rayed then it
get away
now wait that's a tie or is it oh it's a
tight it's an easter egg okay he's just
standing there like a little [ __ ] my
brother is dying out there you are
who puts a scalpel there
alright alright hey you what a bone saw
alright well like I don't know bone saw
it is yeah I don't know in a box
somewhere oh god are we gonna get
drugged I think we're gonna get drugged
that no drugs for me hey I'll save them
all for later Breaking Bad here I come
breaking Octodad here I come sorry
that's what I meant
nailed it I don't know Stacy dad
grounded me for a week after my last
story what Johnson and the zombie
hurricane was pretty violent it was mine
vested alright begins begin surgery
please watch what am i doing what the
hell is this is that real surgery
what hi Nigel hot hand Nigel atul all
right I'll give Nigel dead saw yes to
solve his legs great Oh No clear the
chest cavity
okay you mean all this inside so while
he's doing it seems a little crazy to me
but
yes there we go whoa
oh no he's hard drunk
Oh God wheezing oh my god get back here
blue all over the place don't why would
they do that stupid kids act come back
here you stupid ah don't worry I got
your heart man mmm his heart will what
is it going anyway
there we go I can hear it - all right
you're not going anywhere
whoa caught it midair [ __ ] it's a
feisty one
you be careful with this why did it
shrink attach the robot limbs that's
disgusting but okay I guess guess cuz
I'm after dad I'll do it and I'm
fabulous Fable a bad whoa what the hell
sorry don't worry about that that's
supposed to happen everyone knows that
you're not a real doctor view can I
reach it can I write back and now we can
get back leg you stupid ho @ there we go
don't worry abut everyone is going wild
what's going on wait a second what what
how did what are you talking back what
what are you go I think he's dead shock
him again oh oh oh oh my brother he
needs to live Nigel why don't you do
something
Nigel Nigel whoa got him again
oh ah got it charge it you will live
good tell you will live good - I love
you yes right in Burt high-five Nigel
we did it quick get it you're the best
around oh god why is it so hard to
high-five uh sorry not foot five no
alright you don't do that
that's how we talk about more than one
how many a brofist yeah that's what I'm
talking about
all right you got a live going to you
kind of live going to I love you hold my
hand Gunter
what's the wheelchairs ah thank you dr.
Nigel
you saved my brother I will never
forgive you I mean I will always love no
wait I will let's go off to the sunset
together going to get in the chair go to
don't fight me
koonta good job I say go in then go it
thank you no stop
good job and recap nailed it how is he
not in the wheelchair what are you
talking about
there we go alright let's go coming
through
everybody stay clear it's Gunter here
that rhymed oh my god Gunter it's very
happy
I've got uphill I gotta work those sonic
powers why do I even bother saving this
[ __ ] I don't even like him ever go
butcher son god dammit
good Terry as high as [ __ ] don't worry
about it he'll be fine I think I think
one can only hope
there we go we're in this room but uh
but dad got unicorn ideas from that
oh no not unico nightís jet skis Hey we
bought some sweet jet ski okay I'm okay
with that actually best story ever told
I am crying real tears
I was just beautiful oh my god that was
the shorts that was amazing
alright friends if you enjoyed watching
please go ahead and leave a like I
really much appreciate it as always I
hope there's more shorts coming out I
would I would love to see that but I
don't know but if I will I'll be sure to
play it and let me know if you want me
to see more as always stay awesome bros
love you Baja